Oh
ozium woodgreen constituency declaration
of result of Paul I Nick walkley being
the acting returning officer at the
election of one member of parliament for
the horns Ian Wood Green constituency
held on the 7th of may 2015 do hereby
give notice that the number of votes
recorded for each candidate at the said
election is as follows Featherstone Lynn
Liberal Democrats 18350 9 motherson
Clive Winston UK Independence Party you
Kip 1271 Mosley Jeff hoi polloi 45
Peter's Gordon Green Party 3146 Rahu gia
suhail the Conservative Party candidate
5347 spy be van Christian People's
Alliance 118 Sweeney Frank workers
Revolutionary Party 82 west catherine
elizabeth labour party 29
but the number of ballot papers rejected
was as follows want of official mark nil
voting for more than one candidate 62
writing or remark by which the
vertically identified one being on
marked or holy void for uncertainty a
hundred and fourteen the total rejected
was a hundred and seventy-seven and I do
hereby declare that the said Catherine
Elizabeth West is duly elected
thank you so much for that wonderful
applause and I really am delighted to
have one tonight despite it being quite
a difficult night across the piece for
some labour colleagues we know that not
all the results are in but it's a very
mixed picture for us I'd like also to
put on record my thanks to the outgoing
Member of Parliament Lynne Featherstone
for all of her hard work for the
community and we really don't know
what's going to happen next but one
thing I do know is that if it's going to
be a tory-led government that we have in
the coming months that we here will not
give up we will continue the fight to
protect our NHS we will take up the
cudgels to defend people with
disabilities we will fight to scrap the
bedroom tax and we will fight for a
fairer future for our young people
tuition fees must be cut we will
continue to fight for fairer housing
policies and we will continue to fight
for the future which our young people so
desperately need could I also just thank
all my agent Matt Downey and all his
team for those of you who know the story
of this seat two years ago I was
selected by the horns II would bring
Labour Party and it's been really I've
put my heart and soul into it and
I just want to say thank you to all of
my not just our volunteers but the
leadership from local government in
London local government counselors in
London have just put their huge energy
and support and really that's what's
done it for us so huge thank you to all
my counselor colleagues for their
support and I hope now we can all get
some sleep thank you